[Musique]
non non non non Kevin l'a fait faire le laisser
faire non non je vais le faire je vais le faire
[Musique]
Walter regarde ces adorables petits monstres
se dirigent vers Orlando - tu vas devenir
méchant  -con n'êtes-vous pas je vais demander à tous
mes méchants préférés de signer mon magazine
écarlate surpuissant si j'étais un minion
c'est pour qui je voudrais travailler pour des
criminels et n'importe quel talent maléfique et
vous tous les talents maléfiques oh oh c'est
pas mal ou un talent
n'est-ce pas si bon d'être mauvais
quoi pour moi et tous tes rêves deviennent
réalité respect power banana Wow il a gardé
euh peut-être que je vais les calmer avec une
histoire au coucher je pense mon pote il était une
fois là-bas  étaient trois petits cochons
les gâteaux ont rencontré un grand méchant loup il a
embauché les trois cochons pour venir travailler pour
elle un jour les cochons c'est quelque chose de très
stupide alors le loup souffle et souffle et elle
ne l'a pas fait